well Envy energy the sponsors of today's
segment offer a home energy saver
service that can help lower your energy
bills every month here to tell us more
from NV Energy is Patricia Rodriguez
Patricia so great to see you again great
to see you too thank you for having me
thank you for being here a lot to talk
about today and let's jump right to it
so the appliances that we have in our
home that we use probably on a daily
basis those really contribute to our
monthly Energy bill can you tell us a
little bit about that yes absolutely so
large appliances do contribute to the
bill and one of the things that we have
right now with our home energy saver is
an opportunity to get some discounts to
get smarter appliances so you can save
additional funds when you're using
appliances yeah so what is the saver
service how does it work and how can
your customers kind of learn more about
it so the safer service is the new
program that we have where we give
instant discounts for large appliances
at Century tillers as a Home Depot
Lowe's and RC Willey's so when you're
out shop shopping looking for the what
should you be looking for when it comes
to getting those appliances there is the
sticker that has power shift in it and
that's the way that you know that that
Appliance qualifies for the um you know
for the instant discount and right now
that everybody's shopping for Christmas
right that's a great opportunity and
this is the gift that keeps keeps on
giving because not only will you save on
the instant discount but as using those
small appliances you'll be saving on
your energy bill yeah so when you see
that certification on those appliances
you're looking for overall they use less
energy that can help lower your bill is
that kind of the connection between it
all yes and they're also better for the
environment they're usually you know
energy start so that's a big clue right
but uh very excited to offer this
customer this product for our customers
and you mentioned it being the holidays
and there's always great deals out there
but also just in general do you have any
tips for people at home that they should
keep in mind when it comes to their
monthly energy especially throughout
December and into January absolutely
keep your thermostat at 68 degrees trees
when you're home and a little bit lower
if you're not home open the blinds
during the daytime so the sunlight can
get into your home and warm it up a
little bit so and obviously we have an
in-home energy assessment call us so we
can go and help you see where your
energy usage is going to we have Smart
thermostats so we have the whole deal so
just call in the energy and slash power
shift awesome well I have seen those
assessments happen in person and I see
how much that they can help you or
household and just saving money overall
so Patricia thank you so much for being
here remember keep that thermostat at 68
for more information you can go to
nvenergy.com
appliances Las Vegas now we'll be right
back
[Music]